what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation Greg and Aaron Alexander are back for
more of one piece we are watching episode five
today Aaron how are you my friend I'm well I'm
swell I'm John Cena you can't even see me boy I
can't I cannot see you because I don't see color
damn straight yes not gone you feel me you're not
robbing me are you okay I'm sorry I'm going home
I'm sorry this is the last one Piece
episode he's canceled make a racist remark
on my behalf I've made so many racist remarks
on your behalf now it's a problem [Laughter]
that's our intro leave a like
appreciate satire And subscribe and
click that notification like you're
notified when our reaction to the next
episode one piece is up here on this
channel oh as always full interesting
with your own copy one piece available
for supersection rejects over at our patreon
page thank you to all who have joined certain
people have pledged to watch us watch One
Piece with watching us let's get to it
[Music]
thank you just call that guy Grandpa
what a Twist the villain chasing him
his own grandfather maybe it's not
his real Grandpa he just had him
call Grandpa it's my first ship
had your time on this maybe he's
not his real Grandpa you're right
a little excessive I mean just talk to
the kid you are training begins today
[Music] he was abusive [Music]
does Grandpa know that he's stretchy that straw
hat he's going after his grandson oh I don't
think so yeah no load the cannon in the barrel
light the fuse and get the hell out of the way
oh no oh God and you want to
be captives you had one job
he must know because if they can see him then he
must be able to see them lawyer
sales and submit to my authority
another year away yeah he knows yeah 100 but
his grandpa have some gum gum whoa Grandpa must
[Music] okay damn damn
he saved his life out of all the
stretching Loop he's done that
was probably the most cartoony
thing he's done so far love it
let's go through a wide rail of emotions right now
like hot bad boy yeah he's like angry
and proud and he likes a challenge yeah
[Music] they could still unload their cannons
this show makes me want to watch
the anime this show makes me want
to be a thief seal the season
commit crimes who is this duck
knife and fork interesting interesting indeed you
guys smell that there's something on the breeze
smells like butter use your super nostrils
expand them really gotta get out of this fog
I know but I smell food means that there's
someone somewhere cooking there's a place
nearby that's out of the fog sail through the
fog three degrees back to Port add food to the
equation and suddenly he knows how to navigate
what is that is that land at a restaurant [Music]
oh fascinating it's like a port in the middle
of the ocean that's really cool yeah what a
cool world right let's build this world more come
on there's like a theme park here to build man oh
totally let's get one piece land come on do you
have a reservation sir do we need one we're very
full today I could put you on the waiting list
it's three weeks out jeez you wouldn't want to
turn away the future king of the Pirates now would
you and who is that sir Monkey D Luffy perhaps
you've heard of him we'll find a table yeah I knew
it in three weeks can't they just eat at the bar
of course happy hour right
this way man when he talks
I'd be happy to check your swords
for you sir just take them off bro
who are you get a move on if you're slowing the
line I'm gonna wait for the source to cool hey
you better keep it on the menu whatever the hell
that is boss man ain't gonna like you I don't know
who this guy is but I already like him what the
hell is this I call it a true blue film saute
it's elephant tuna see it asparagus in a sweet soy
production I cannot tell what this man's accent is
sounds French is but it's not like thick though
I'll freezes off I gotta sling one more prime
rib medium well I am going to drop dead of
boredoms you oh [__] that's what we said
insult to the meat tonight you are off the line
now get out there on white tables unbelievable
he has great hair and you treat him like that
shameful you know the rules here we don't waste
food and there is no fight in aparati after he
apologizes for his Bad Manners Over My Dead Body
oh okay footwork oh oh he's one of them
lanky anime characters with the legs
hands in Pocket also it's such a cool really
brought that to life it's so cool it's got
the Swagger yes apologies Madam I didn't
see you there would you care for the pair
of thief to stop something sweet for someone
sweet nothing wrong with your eye just Blended
he's my favorite character that was your
favorite character he's my favorite over
this kanji yeah he's my favorite character
we're making progress sir but the ship is
in need of repairs we've got to shore up the
yard reinforce the portion has this guy done
anything yet no but does he have a sword he has
a sword there's like a samurai sword yeah he's
wearing a suit he must have a history with
Zorro in some way oh that would make sense
New York did I catch you
in the middle of something
about he canceled just killing some
time all right whoa what the sword
I have a request for you who's the Quarry
oh great wire work what an intro
doesn't sound like much of a challenge
he looks like a young Tom Cruise I see
Sasha Baron Cohen I can see that wow one moment
I am
no I can't unsee it he's my favorite
character it's time I ended this
oh he's dead 17 million huh
prepared to die why are you after me
you woke me from my nap [Music]
[Laughter] holy oh rap whoa damn
[Applause]
we're like 10 minutes in and we
got an introduction with three
cool new characters oh man this is awesome [Music]
we got the death of one of
the three cool new characters
and mihawk bring him alive by any means
necessary I can't eat another bite but it's
so good I feel you man I have the same problem
relatable to the best cruise sailing on the sea
and do our Victory how are you gonna pay for
this what victory exactly against the Marines
our very first battle line we crushed him
I don't know how many naval battles you
guys have been a part of who doesn't at
least but [Laughter] you didn't think to
mention that your grandfather was a marine
and not just any Marine a vice admiral no
one would have known I was there as opposed
to wrecking a base Commander's office oh God
knows that thank you
you give them like a very generous tip I guess
but variety doesn't offer credit as soon as I
find a one piece I'm gonna come back here pay this
bill in full I need a drink now you're talking
how does Zoro survive as an alcoholic you're
gonna pay off your debt washing dishes wait
the next three episodes he's just washing dishes
you can keep me out of the kitchen all you like
I'll never be a waiter well that's fine by
me because you sure as they were never going
to be a cook in my restaurant oh tell them how
good it tastes you seriously don't think what
Luffy did is messed up what's advice I can't
get caught not when I'm so close to what to
what who are you talking to if I wanted to secure
passage to the Konomi Islands who would I talk to
costume six thousand I have buried it was just
regular random looking white man what's going on
here I'm a slip 22. be ready to sail a dorm you're
not going to vet this guy at all to make sure that
no I trust you just showed up what you said
back at syrup Village oh God I'm starting to
think you might be right about it of course I'm
right you ever hear of anyone called me Hawk
better with a blade than anyone in living
history one of the seven Warlords at the
Seas so what you're saying he's gonna
fight Zoro at one point why would the
more weddings need to work with pirates to do
the things they didn't want tied back to them
in exchange the Warlords were given free reign
so sorry what you're learning about the Marines
you may know how to tie a knot but you
don't know [__] about how the world works
dirty Marines you need to just go join Luffy man
get with the program join the team have a change
of heart in the season finale the old man's a
real piece of work but you regret giving them
the IOU I don't really do regret sometimes
when I try to look ahead all I see is back
that's a poignant line but that meal you
cook was incredible I should be running
this place but the old man's so stubborn
it'll never happen so that's your dream
Luffy always hones in on what people's dreams
are this place where you can find ingredients
from more forces there's fish there that
have never been seen Rass seaweed spices
especially with this jazz music playing that's
my dream if you want to cook you should cook let
them cook sorry I couldn't help myself stand
up to him tell him what you want it's more
or something
I got Noir quality to this Sanji guy
yeah the coolness and the cigarettes
I'm so hungry please okay please cook me a meal
it's the business we can't be giving handouts to
every down on his left pirate that washes up so
man is hungry I feed him good man he's gonna cook
a whole meal it's not like a piece of bread the
guys the guy's starving it'll be yeah 30 minutes
like oh I need this guy yeah you should join
my crew sorry Joe boy I've already got a job
but you're not happy here and we're gonna need
a great cook if we're gonna find the one piece
what did you say we were searching for it
too I was part of a mighty pirate Armada oh
the guy who just died hmm the grand line was his
undoing we lost 50 ships and 5 000 men damn off
of one sword forget you ever heard of the one
piece settle for cleaning dishes oh hell yeah
look at him like he doesn't have a care in the
world what are you carrying around that's so
heavy I bet I know more about you than you do
about me yeah right make it a drinking game
I get something about you you drink
hey it's not real alcohol YouTube
I bet you grew up in a big city I
grew up in a village barely available
it just a handful of houses in the
center of a tangerine Grove she's lying
she thinks she's lying how do you know women
lie hashtag I'll bet you didn't have any
friends as a kid I had one friend how long
more than I had they're gonna get plastered
we're gonna be really good friends by the
end of the night maybe she was telling the
truth yeah believe them ah [__] believe
her is it true you're sending your cool
mihawk after Luffy I signed an oath to protect
people to treat everyone equally under the law
that's not the case maybe I'm not meant to
be a marine dude don't do this on his ship
well out in the middle of the ocean while he's
eating is a criminal come on I joined the Marines
over 50 years ago I give him a simple ideals
but I had to adapt the same set of laws do not
apply to everyone but that's not fair no it's not
life isn't fair I could have been Fleet Admiral I
know but always turned down the promotion because
I'd have to do things their way I'll be losing my
freedom freedom is everything Marines are all
that are standing between order and Anarchy
I wonder if this guy really believes you yeah
sure he does yeah a uniform it's starting to
fit you after all he did take a stand when
normally he wouldn't and again and again
down goes the yard Marie's dead in
the water oh oh you're the captain
technically no I did distract him so that
Luffy was like the official Captain dude
stop talking talk too damn much that's
your problem be my new best friend
oh God he just looks like a bad guy you're a
Dracula mihawk or knows exactly of course he
does he's a sword fanatic I've been following
your career since I was a child which is why
it pains me to inform you that tomorrow will
be your last day you're going to die all right
Zoro challenge you called it called it to the
death let's go what if they kill off Zorro nah
lifelong dream it's the best you in single combat
and become the greatest swordsman in the world he
has receive his goal then I'm going to kill him
dude tomorrow at dawn and when I'm done with
you pirate Hunter I'll take your captain no no
okay it's probably gonna be something we're like
Zorro gets really injured and we think he's dead
but he's just gonna be healed it's gonna be like
this Marvel show things or then do one of those
things where it's like a tie but something breaks
it up and they have to like have the rematch
later no I think it's gonna get a really badly
you may have abandoned him from the line
but you can't stop him from cooking this
starving pirate washed up earlier you did he
cooked for him right here in your kitchen he
did what matter less to him than making
sure a hungry man got fat talk too much
tell your first mate he's going to get himself
tell your navigator to Bud Al when you met me
tied up on that cross what did I say what
makes you think I want to play pirates with
you and you made a promise to someone a long
time ago to be the world's greatest Swordsman
beat mihawk in a duel and take his
title even if you die in the process
you know I had enough character development yeah
you're not there yet buddy yeah to go through like
at least three more arcs in story before you can
like achieve that you're the best I've ever seen
but tell them you love him but I didn't give
a [__] because you're my friend you idiot
you said it yourself dude
[Music] bro you're my least favorite character
ah he's still my favorite oh my God are
they gonna fight this episode I thought
they were gonna fight next episode right
Sam happened to Netflix really stretching
their [__] out come on milk it
so I can complain about it later
what they are because he said
yeah you said it Dawn or like
the next day I think it's funny this
episode okay cool the choreography
and the wire work is gonna be crazy
or very disappointing or very brief
you have a choice to make you
have a choice stay with your
people you have to become a crew you have a friend
nah dude yeah Zorro's gonna get his ass kicked
it's so badass looking yeah
he really is let's begin
[Music]
oh little blade yeah I don't hunt
rabbits with a cannon [Laughter]
wow damn what a cocky line let's go
yeah he's gonna whoop his ass yeah
[__] damn
nice hardly God what is this strength ridiculous
does he have a fruit too from croaking in a well
[__] I love this [Music]
dude one of us will become the
world's greatest swords to ever live
I just realized young Zoro kind
of looks like Ezra Miller [Music]
that's not enough to kill him though I
powerful that blade is why don't you retreat
oh he's gonna give him another chance can't
well my dream will be lost forever
you're brave I'll give you that
he barely poked him so I'll do you
the honor of killing you with yorun
oh
wow that leaves an impression get that
one sword man put it in your mouth
yeah let's go
come on
what just happened so scared
[Music] oh no
oh no you broke his swords no he didn't cut
him did he no okay good wounds on the back
our swordsman's greatest shame magnificent
Jesus no no no y'all Let Him Live he has to no he
has to avenge him he has to beat him one day he's
fight for his honor oh no way no they did not
just dude [Music] no way he did not kill this
guy no okay no no it's gonna go down the Marvel
interest character path please oh he's a scar to
always remember him what's your goal I'm going
to become the king of the Pirates it's a much
more treacherous path than even defeating
me um that's what I'm going to do maybe
you Willard there this guy's a great character
yeah Roanoke Zora it's too soon for you to die
grow strong and come find me yeah I told
you I told you you would get really injured
said it's too soon for you to die if I fail
to become the world's greatest swordsman you'll
be disappointed right no could never fail me
never God I love these characters huh
what are you talking about that's right
the greatest Swordsman it starts with
healing I will never lose again oh let's go
sorrow
sorrow episode 545 he's gonna
fight him I can't wait see
seven nine Netflix I know what you're doing
you want me to watch The Next Episode I get
it oh I get it I get it you make me think
he's dead no no no no no no no in the next
episode starts and he's fun you're not gonna
trick me yeah you can't trick me I know what
you're doing silly games Netflix I know what
you're doing you think you're clever what is
hat guy's name Luffy no no no the guy who looks
like Zorro I don't know mustache chin strap God
he's great he's so good he's great I introduced
two great characters there I love the Sanji is
his name Sanji Sanji that's his name Sanji um
has such an Exquisite charm to him such Elegance
um Debonair quality I would say great word
Debonair yes yeah I think he the way he carries
himself I love it and then there's another guy
who carries himself with such regality as well
the this uh [__] um mustache trolling guy with
the coldness in his demeanor excellent yeah I love
it mustache swirl man yeah pull out other words
but I can't pull out names um it's okay this has
been our strong suit with this show but it's it's
a lot of names with a lot of characters yeah but
man what a setup I love how this show just cuts
when I'm so used to Netflix sometimes delivering
shows are just like stretch out you know and and
and so I really thought like there's there's a
point in here where I'm like I'm enjoying this
but is this gonna drag on like this specifically
this episode like are they gonna really like just
lounge around this restaurant the whole time like
I'm liking getting to know these characters and
stuff but what is this episode really going to
be about is this going to be a filler of some
sort and and then I like how it just kind of
cuts through the the [__] you know like we get
enough character build up we get enough character
set pieces we get uh Nami and Zorro bonding with
each other establishing the Friendship of you
know not me having the choice of do I go solo
on this bathroom stick her with a friend like
getting that character beat but then also you
know like how you were calling the second thick
guy showed up I was always gonna fight this guy
and then the show kind of just knows that and so
let's get that fight let's get that set up there
and then we get this really impactful fight like
no episode has been a waste of time you know if
this was the anime it would have taken 15 episodes
yeah he did it way too quick I remember him for
Live Action it's great I love it the characters
are great like it's a great character and it still
feels so animated and vibrant yeah yeah I know
it feels animated and vibrant and the fact that
it's able to capture the the tonality of an anime
while also not feeling like it's overdoing it or
feeling like it's it's out of place for this for
this show or for being in live action everything
in this in this episode for me was incredible from
the fact that we got that fight in the beginning
and seeing Luffy confront his grandfather from a
distance to then him discovering the restaurant
and then meetings uh meeting Sanji I I loved it
and then all the action here was incredible this
episode The Wire work the the way that they did
choreography it's like they found a way to make
this heightened thing super cool without like
going like over the top like like Michael Bay
or like I don't know some like some stuff you
see in movies it's perfectly anime without like
Jumping the Shark and I don't know if how to like
explain that in a way where it makes sense because
literally anime is like is heightened action and
heightened emotions but they found a way to make
it grounded and accessible we get heightened at
the same time and found that perfect line
to walk to uh have the optimal amount of
both of them well what the show exceptionally
excels at too is introducing characters and
getting you invested in them quickly quickly
it's surprising how quick they do it because
they did that with two characters this time and
they introduced oh my God I'm so bad with names
the newest guy to the crew the newest
guy to the crew oh stop [Music]
um they did that with they just they just do
that all around with everyone and I I really
do love how quickly I'm like oh wow I love this
character already I love this character already
and they they're so distinguished as well you
know and the World building again with this like
restaurant Pirate Bay where they can all
congregate didn't eat here like I think
that's really neat so everything about this has
been really Pleasant and I'm also loving the
journey that it's putting Luffy on because the way
what this episode did in particular I thought with
Luffy and Zorro because Zorro is is like the cool
calm Jada guy that whenever he's around you know
he just seems like you just feel like you're safe
when he's around like he's gonna handle [__]
right yeah yeah yeah and you needed this element
of stakes for him to the point where when he gets
he gets in a fight he loses badly and quickly you
know so you need that for the character and it it
this is the most emotionality we've seen propelled
out of like pulled out of him in that final moment
to get you really I was already invested in his
goal and invested in everything but to give it a
to just have it be I want to be the greatest
swordsman is kind of broad right but to make
it a specific match that he has to go up against
makes it a lot more personal and tangible for an
audience member to latch onto so I'm glad
they introduced this so early on yeah and
then for Luffy he's all about inspiring people
and then he made he he gave the the words of
encouragement to Zorro as well um saying like
Okay this is your dream you should go do it
and as Captain as leader I don't know what the
show is really going to do but I imagine it's
going to come with some level of regret because
clearly what this show's has been doing is on
top of that is Luffy's so much of the person who
instills optimism and exudes optimism and this
episode was really hinting at us even more so
because yeah they showed this pass through the
group with the pirate stuff and why they look
like there was a lot of rough upbringing there
this experience of this grandpa is like oh this
is the first form of like this guy was abused
you know he had abuse in his life right and that
really hinted at he's got a lot of darkness in
him as well yeah yeah and this is the first
episode that truly shined a light on that
so I love that we're peeling back the layers
of the care so not only are we getting new
characters that seem really cool we're also
peeling back the layers more of the characters
we've already been on board with yeah yeah
yeah and I think they they do it in a way where
it gives us more information about the characters
and endears us to them but also endearing them
to each other and yeah it's like the the perfect
folding of those two things and yeah watching them
kind of go through these these trials and
tribulations the fact that Zorro lost his
first fight of the series so far only makes us
root for him more because you see the the courage
and tenacity he has and his desire to succeed
and yeah I think that they they all have this
this sort of quality about them the fact that
they all have these these lifelong dreams or
desires and you know I feel like us as people we
all have those things that we want to achieve and
I think that's the access point of this show
is the fact that these are dreamers going out
dreamers and loners coming out together to both
move towards a common goal true and outside of it
being anime or being like a property that already
exists I think that's foundationally is something
that that resonates and can bring people together
whether they are anime fans or not I think just
watching this show and and knowing that we are
people that have things that we want to achieve
as individuals and then seeing those people's
individuals come together not only for a common
goal but United as what will eventually I
assume will form as a family a chosen family
um yeah really really resonates and it's gonna
destroys a lot of heart the show is like oozing
with heart and action and character and Charisma
and yeah I'm just I'm loving it I'm loving the
journey so far Nick loving yeah it's great man
it's great stuff guys what'd you think about
this episode thank you so much for everyone
that's been on this journey with us uh it's
been a really fun journey and I can't wait
to see the next three episodes uh we're gonna
watch episode six right now uh but before so
please subscribe leave a like uh check us on
patreon thank you to all who've been joining
but before we go listen to the patron of the
day shout out Michael B Omni media ladies and
gentlemen this guy is one of the best reaction
channels out there he's also a great friend
I knew him as a great reaction channel before
became a great friend that's my requirement before
I become friends of their reaction channels is
going are they a good reaction Channel all right
then I'll be your friend and Michael B he's one
of them and he's also covering one piece right
now I haven't watched any of his videos for it
yet I'm assuming they're great based off his
tweets and how much enthusiasm he has for the
show but you know I just it's a show that I'm
we're also covered I don't want to watch anyone
else because because they're my enemy they're my
competition at the moment now I still want to be
influenced and steal your opinions like I normally
do but guys go so so so so so those who though so
I don't see color show your support
to Michael B today [Laughter] Omni media that's
omn one what a weird spelling man Jesus you
probably get better views if you just spelled your
name properly oh hard is this time just change the
one who and I it's o m n is it Nancy one media
that's a complicated asking the time man it's
complicated he found a following with it I'm sure
you know more because there's strategic thing even
more man you should change it it's complicated
you say an omni anyway it was taken what happens
if I type in Omni media not Omni one media but
okay if you pop up then there's no question here
um media yeah you still pop up here okay there's
no point in me saying anything all right damn dude
your [__] video got 50k views on this video we
just covered way out of this episode [Laughter]
to this now I was like anxiety first don't watch
his videos it's already doing well we have to win
[Music]